yeah i mean like for one thing if you if
you google your name the first thing you
see is all these
random weird little blogs that are like
hit pieces on you
and who you are like you're a womanizer
you're this terrible person you abandon
your family
right and all this stuff so these are
all websites created by these people
right and they pay on your name they pay
for them
to be at the top of searches on my name
like they spend tax exempt dollars on
that [ __ ]
and on hiring private investigators to
go through my trash or
set up cameras outside my house or put
gps
tracking devices on my cars or show up
like i have been all over the world
since i left scientology like i went to
england a couple of times because i was
interviewed by the bbc
there would be scientology protesters
there i went to australia to be
interviewed by brian seymour
at channel 7. they sent private
investigators
on the plane with me who followed me
around
in australia with cameras i went to
ireland
they had protesters at the airport when
i landed in ireland
this the amount of money that gets spent
on this
is insane and
it is actually being subsidized by
taxpayers
because scientology has tax exempt
status
so that money is not only
tax-free it's not
there's no accounting for it there is no
oversight of what scientology spends its
money on
right there's absolutely zero regulation
on them nope and there is no way for the
irs
even to require go in and do an audit
or require them to report nothing
there is a there is a law in the united
states called the church audits
procedures act
which basically prevents the irs from
doing anything with a religious
organization
now explain that what was that like that
whole
the whole fight to get the tax
to get scientology to be tax exempt
because i know there was
there was two stages of it right
obviously the first stage which led to
the fbi raids and all that stuff early
on
when they found out what scientology was
trying to do
but then again there was the thing with
all the lawsuits that were filed
what was how did that whole war against
the irs come about
and what was that what was it like being
in your position doing that
okay um that war
against the irs came about partly
because of the dictates of
l ron hubbard who joined watergate
thanks
who said that you know the irs is an
enemy
and taxation is bad and blah blah blah
blah
because they had denied scientology tax
exempt status early originally they
granted it and then
denied it saying that money was being
funneled to hubbard
and that was what's called enument which
is a violation you can't have
a person benefiting from something that
is tax exempt
like personally right you can be paid
you know
the head of national geographic gets
paid even though
it's a tax-exempt organization but if
the head of national geographic
was getting huge royalties from the sale
of
national geographic right that would not
that would eliminate their qualification
for tax exemption
when el run hubbard died he
had a will and his will said
that the money that he had accumulated
and the rights to his
writings which were both fiction and
the scientology writings which are all
copyrighted
every single word that he ever wrote
is copyrighted and royalties are paid on
by every church of scientology
and every sale of every book that
all of that money and that revenue
stream were to go to an
organization that was dedicated to
preserving his technology
and technology is a term that hubbard
used to describe
his writings and the scripture of
scientology
and he used technology because he always
tried to present scientology as very
scientific
this isn't belief this is where religion
meets science you may have seen some of
the ads that scientology does
they do one a year usually at the super
bowl and
one of the lines do they really yeah i
don't think i've ever seen a scientology
super bowl ad
oh yeah really yes
yeah okay um
yeah i wish we had i wish i had one i
could see but that's that's nice oh you
can find them online
yeah just google scientology super bowl
ad they're like
every year that's unbelievable and
you'll see that they often
say this is where science meets religion
you know this is the
the culmination of eastern philosophy
and western material i mean
all this stuff anyway hobbit called this
stuff
technology okay and he decreed
in his will that he
this his
money that he had accumulated you know a
few hundred million dollars i guess and
the revenue streams from future
because those those royalties continue
to be paid
were to vest in an organization which is
called the church of spiritual
technology and the church of spiritual
technology was an organization that was
established to preserve
the writings and recorded lectures of l
ron hubbard
on stainless steel etched into
stainless steel stored in titanium
pods in nuclear-proof
vaults dug into the side of mountains
i know that sounds really bizarre but
that is hubbard's legacy
he wanted his materials to survive what
he said was the coming nuclear holocaust
on planet earth
so that future civilizations
it would still be available to them they
could dig this [ __ ] up out of the
the vaults and there it would be all
preserved
wonderfully and this has been
hundreds of millions of dollars have
been spent
putting you know his millions and
millions of words and thousands of
lectures
on to industry into into indestructible
form
and buried in vaults in new mexico and
in california
okay that's like i said i digress a lot
because there's
so much to these things
the requirement for that to happen
was that the church of spiritual
technology had to have
tax-exempt status because he didn't want
his estate to be paying taxes on the
transfer
of the money to the organization
okay okay the irs refused to grant
tax-exempt status to the church of
spiritual technology
and scientology sued
and lost and at that point
david miscavige who was now
responsible for conducting the affairs
of scientology and carrying out the
wishes
of l ron hubbard in his will had a
problem
there was this estate sitting there with
hundreds of millions of dollars with
orders to preserve the technology
and he didn't have a way of getting that
done
and scientologists believe
that when you die you come back
again in another body
and miscavitch was worried that hubbard
was coming back
and would be like what the [ __ ] dude
how come you haven't gotten this done he
thought that his spirit
or what they call it thetan yeah state
and spirit would somehow
after he died they said that it left his
body and he went to do research as just
a spirit and that he truly believed he
would come back
into a human meat sack
and yes and hubbard had written
here is how you will know who i am this
is how i will be identifiable
really yes and how is that how i have no
idea okay
i don't know i don't care um
but but that then
started what was seriously
the war on the irs if we can't get the
irs to agree
to granting tax-exempt status to the
church of spiritual technology
and we can't get the courts to agree we
are going to
force the irs to agree
and this is where fair game comes in
because what happened was
a very very intense campaign was
conducted
against the irs and against individual
agents in the irs and in the hierarchy
of the irs
that were responsible for tax exempt
or religious tax-exempt organizations
okay and there were
like you talk about these smear sites
back in the day that was it was sort of
pre-internet but there were magazines
that scientology published called
freedom magazine and these people were
put on the cover of freedom magazine
private investigators were sent
into irs conventions and documented
irs agents getting drunk at conventions
they sent women in
like everything that you can and filed a
thousand lawsuits
against the well let me back up
part of the strategy was to request
freedom of information
make freedom of information requests to
all
irs offices around the country
and to because what happens
when when you get a a document release
under freedom of information you see
right blacked out
but the same document may be in five
different offices
and you'll get different blackouts from
different offices okay
and if you've got enough people which
scientology has plenty of people and
plenty of money
you can sit and compare all these and
and start
noticing okay here's the
this line was blacked out on this
document that we got from
san antonio but the same line is not
blacked out on the document we got from
sacramento
so now we know that that and now we also
know
that this was a [ __ ] blackout what
was why were they what were they
blacking out
they black out uh names of people
or things that they think are protecting
confidential informants
or like there's all sorts of things that
are justified
in blacking out in a in a freedom of
information act document okay
so what happened was scientology filed
lawsuits
where they refused to provide documents
or where they provided documents
that were differently
vetted okay and ultimately ended up with
about a thousand
and filed lawsuits on behalf of
individual
scientology parishioners who had had
their deductions to scientology denied
they paid money to scientology and
claimed it as a deduction
yep they were denied so they filed
individual lawsuits
and who told them to do this the office
of special affairs you
yeah okay well not me personally but
people that work for me
and this was all part of the campaign
that was directed by david miscavige to
force the irs into what's called a more
amenable frame of
mind and that is one of hubbard's
writings where he takes a thing
from this from either sun
tzu or klausowitz out of war
on war these books that he studied that
he then
laid out these directives for
scientology to follow and said
the the aim of war
is to get your enemy into a more
amenable frame of mind
and that was the objective with the irs
get them into a more amenable frame of
mind
i